hi I'm Matt Welch with Nick Gillespie
we're on ask a libertarian Day 2012 to
mark the paperback publication of the
Declaration of Independence which we
co-wrote together we are taking your
questions the next one comes by email
mark drawn aka windy pundit where are
the black people mark writes or any
other minorities when I saw you guys in
the book signing in Chicago a city that
hasn't been majority white for some time
I could only see one non-white person in
the room and I think he was the rep from
the bookstore why do so few minorities
identify themselves as libertarians and
what can we do about it sounds like a
question for Nick it's a it's a fair
question political movements tend or the
libertarian political movement
sociologically has been mostly white
mostly male the country is no longer
mostly male or mostly white
if the libertarian moment is really
going to be upon us and say we need to
reach out to all sorts of people I think
that we are gathering more steam among
minorities you see this in term or
ethnic and racial minorities partly
because a lot of the issues we deal with
whether it's things like war policy and
soldiering and bombing countries
indiscriminately in the third world drug
policy and its effects on ethnic and
racial minorities in America or
what-have-you
we're starting to move in that area but
we need to actually make sure that we're
reaching all of the people who would
benefit from our libertarian
prescriptions I'm gonna make a strange
analogy here which is the expansion of
NATO bear with me here for a second a
lot of people especially libertarians I
would say didn't really understand why
Poland and the Czech Republic and other
people wanted to join NATO well they did
because they'd known what it's like when
people with more power than them live
near them and make the rules and so they
wanted a guarantee of their safety I
think the most persecuted historically
of American citizens will go towards a
large organization that says explicitly
we are going to protect you from the
other guys and I think that's what has
happened in American politics with
african-americans since the great sort
of realignment
in the 1960s and third parties in
general this isn't just a libertarian
party this is the Green Party I cover
Ralph Nader in 2000 through an
impersonal in the audience and you'd go
to a st. Louis you know it's the same
thing why what power do you are you
gonna bring as a third party to help
protect my interest it's a tough sell
it's an intellectual sell and I think
you're gonna see a lot more crossover as
people talk about not necessarily how
are you going to win this election but
how are you going to reshape this policy
in particular that predominantly or
disproportionately affects certain
communities we see this with the
opposition to the stop and frisk program
in New York and across a bunch of
different other lines so I think it's
gonna be on an issue-by-issue basis much
more than on a major party power
politics basis that's ask a libertarian
2012 we'll be back in a few minutes